just could I just divert a story that
you and I had and once where we went to
the airport and you smoked inside the
airport no but it was against the law no
but this is what would get me mad with
that [ __ ] yeah alright this will get
me mad yeah even to this day they come
on the loudspeaker no I don't smoke
anymore I just hold them I know okay and
they start in you know with the this is
a non-smoking area yeah
and I'm gone you stupid [ __ ] hasn't it
been a non-smart
can somebody just shut the tape no
smoking supposedly for 35 years yeah in
in this [ __ ] lax where people are
getting killed now when they come out
from a flight because now there's no
cars allowed to pull over have you been
to the worst [ __ ] airport in the
history of human beings yeah people are
running across the street to the parking
structure and causes stopping short and
people are throwing their [ __ ] bags
and I don't know how to get home anymore
it's the worst [ __ ] setup I [ __ ]
hate them
no but now it's also like you can't get
a cab there anymore other area which is
never gonna happen in my world you won't
take a shuttle
no no shuttles caught on fire recently
no they had to switch him back to buses
yeah it's either Avis or Hertz I don't
want to rent the car I wanna get outta
ya you know you all pulled up in the
middle of the gutter there you know and
they open up and people started throwing
their bed it's the worst setup they
really need to do something because
rider gets killed they're down on that
Airport yeah you know it's just not
theirs
it's not safe at all yes alright so what
my mother was telling me
never talk politics because it's a
no-win situation right what you think so
on Facebook you got millions of people
talking puff fighting with each other
unknown people that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about and even if they won known nobody
gives it a lot about them either yeah
that's what you go to a party you see
people with the veins popping out no but
you don't know what I'm said and you
don't know what this one said yeah you
know and I'm looking for the blonde with
big tits that I could drag into a
[ __ ] broom closet
and bang my husband's in the C debate
about what he the chiropractor the
brilliant [ __ ] chiropractor what he
thinks about what needs to be done oh
who gives a [ __ ] you don't even know how
to crack a back properly
you're the worst cutting the doctor
you're a doctor that's a non [ __ ]
doctor in my opinion yeah you're a guy
that they said in school you know he's
never gonna be a heart surgeon it's like
more of a glorified masseuse you know he
rubs you down a little bit some oil he
talks nice into your ear and then he
tries to pop your sparring a little yeah
and he makes himself a nice living and
this is the guy that wants to talk about
the rulers of the world what he thinks
should happen right
[ __ ] yeah well I'm [ __ ] big tits in
the closet you know because that's the
only reason I would go to a party it's
to me checked yeah I don't gift there's
a guy on the block forget about prefer
big tits over tiny little key I like the
Kiwi little tiny kiwi fruit Kiwi fruit
it's whatever you like you know what do
I give a [ __ ]
know what I'm asking you it's no offense
sir I'm saying it's do you like I'm just
referring grab a chick into the closet
they should have a bigger tent so you
always take a fat ass of any kind of
test
you know I mean that's just my personal
preference but I'm there all the time
and I'm gonna just see something the
side note I know I'm not interrupting
you know but I just have a question I
just have a comment to make is your new
girlfriend is so beautiful no I don't
like anybody looking at huh no I'm not
no but you posted on Instagram right
because I follow you okay right and I
look at her could she [ __ ] you [ __ ]
did it
you posted it okay and I made an
observation of going she's very
attractive that she'd look you know
that's all you would never date uncle'
Ana because your daddy's what I'm just
saying is is that when I look at her on
Instagram and just elicits finish all
right let me finish all I'm saying is is
that when I observe her I go she's very
attractive it she seems lovely that's
all congratulate you are you in love did
I say anything about I know what you
think you're getting away with all right
finish the story all right let's say for
instance okay all right so she said
don't talk politics all right so that's
why I don't find a Facebook yeah and
plus they want to put every relative
with a tube up their ass oh my uncle is
104 years old he just passed away yeah
who gives a [ __ ] yeah I got my own prom
we think I got nobody sick hanging
around yeah you know what I mean yeah
this is what they do on Facebook so
that's what I told you forget Twitter
cause only Instagram is the Facebook is
idiot that have failed in life you know
what I mean just failed they failed and
they're angry about failing yes so
they're never gonna write anything nice
to you you know and it's all about you
know the politics and religion religion
religion talk religion no got to be an
[ __ ] to talk religion yeah and this
is what I was taught as a kid and yeah
you know can we talk never talk politics
religion I never and never make fun of
Frank Sinatra why that was a big thing
back then why dumbest I get it you from
Hawaii
I know Frank's to the Rat Pack I know
yeah and I got to meet and hang with
Frank oh you did yes oh wow did you meet
that nice I know I know that's why I'm
nervous that you're on the spot now I'm
happy to be yeah friends we are friends
I love you so you know what's great
about you too is is that if you whenever
you see me I'm one time I saw you on
Larchmont over there and we you were
yeah and you and I had like 30 minute
conversation and you just pull me aside
I just you're just so inclusive